.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY WE CALL
YOU THE GREAT ONE.
MARK LEVIN.
THANK YOU.
WITH MORE REACTION, SENIOR
COUNSEL OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
KELLYANNE CONWAY I'M A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP.
LARA, LET'S GET YOUR THOUGHTS,
AND ALL THAT YOU MIGHT LET YOU
TAKE IT FROM THERE.
>> WELL, I THINK MARK HIT
SOMETHING REALLY IMPORTANT.
THE PROBLEM IS THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY, BY AND LARGE.
THEY HAVE A BIG PROBLEM IN THEIR
HANDS ADDING TO 2022 BECAUSE
NO ONE WANTS TO BUY WITH THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SELLING.
WHAT ARE THEY RUNNING ON?
OPEN BORDERS, INFLATION, EMPTY
SHELVES ALL ACROSS OUR COUNTRY,
HIGH CRIME, DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, MAKING US DEPENDENT ON
FOREIGN OIL AGAIN.
I MEAN, THEY REALLY HAVE GIVEN
AMERICANS NOTHING POSITIVE.
HE IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEIR GOAL AT THE END OF THE DAY
IS TO SOCIALIZE AMERICA.
THAT IS NOT JUST AN UNPOPULAR
MESSAGE IN THIS COUNTRY, IT IS
UN-AMERICAN.
PEOPLE HAVE NOT FLOCKED TO
AMERICA SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
OUR COUNTRY BECAUSE OF
SOCIALISM.
THEY HAVE FLOCKED HERE BECAUSE
OF OUR FREEDOMS, BECAUSE OF OUR
CAPITALIST SYSTEM THAT SAYS IF
YOU COME TO AMERICA, NO MATTER
WHO YOU ARE, NO MATTER WHERE YOU
STARTED, AND YOU HAVE THE WILL
TO WORK HARD AND YOU HAVE A
DREAM, THERE IS NO LIMIT TO WHAT
YOU CAN ACHIEVE.
IN AMERICA, RIGHT NOW, THEY WANT
TO STIFLE THAT.
THEY DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
DREAMS, THEY WANT TO DIVIDE US,
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
FULLY A LOT RELIANCE ON THE
GOVERNMENT GOING FORWARD FROM
HERE ON OUT, SOCIALISM AS MARK T
POINT OUT, HAS NEVER WORKED
ANYWHERE IT HAS BEEN TRIED, AND
QUITE FRANKLY, IF WE DO NOT TAKE
BACK THE HOUSE, THE SENATE IN 22
AND THEN THE WHITE HOUSE IN
'24, WE ARE IN A HUGE MASS AS A
COUNTRY, AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE
CAN EVER RECOVER, BUT NEVER
FORGET WHO BROUGHT IT TO YOU.
A HOUSE, SENATE, AND WHITE HOUSE
FULLY RUN BY DEMOCRATS, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN.
THAT IS WHO HAS BROUGHT YOU THE
TOTAL AND COMPLETE DISASTER THAT
WE HAVE IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
I CAN'T ADD TO THAT.
KELLYANNE, I WILL ASK YOU THE
QUESTION THIS WAY, WE DO KNOW
HOW TO SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS, WE
WANTED TO SOLVE THE BORDER
ISSUE, WE WOULD GO BACK TO THE
TRUMP POLICIES.
WHAT WE WANT TO SOLVE THE ENERGY
ISSUES, WE WOULD GO BACK TO THE
TRUMP POLICIES.
IF WE CARE ABOUT AMERICA'S WE
ABANDONED AFGHANISTAN, WE WOULD
GO IN AND RESCUE THEM SOONER
THAN LATER.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN LEAVING THEM
BEHIND.
THE ECONOMIC DAMAGE THAT IS
BEING DONE IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
OF ENERGY, THIS CAN ALL BE
REVERSED, KELLYANNE, BUT IT IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THIS
RADICAL GROUP OF DEMOCRATS IN
THIS PARTY.
>> NO, AND IF ANYTHING, THEY ARE
TRYING TO IMPOSE THEIR WILL ON
US.
IN FACT, I KNOW PEOPLE CALL THEM
GASES AND MENTAL ACUITY LAPSES,
BUT THEY ARE JUST LIES.
BUILD BACK BETTER COST $0, THAT
IS FALSE.
WE WON'T STRAIN ANYBODY IN
AFGHANISTAN, THAT IS A LIVE.
HE LIES ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND ON
AMTRAK.
ALSO, THAT THE BORDER IS SECURE,
A LIVE, THERE IS NOT A CRISIS, A
LIE, AND WE HAVE TO CALL THEM
LIES, ANOTHER THING AFFECTING
THE POLLS NOW.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT HAVE A
MANDATE AS IT IS BECAUSE HE HAS
A 50/50 SENATE AND A VERY SLIM,
HAIRLINE MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
SO HE DOESN'T HAVE A MANDATE
REALLY IN WASHINGTON, HE DOESN'T
HAVE A MANDATE IN THE POLLS NOW,
AND YET HIS STAFF IS CONVINCED
HE SHOULD BE FDR, SPRINKLED WITH
A LITTLE AOC, AND IT IS A TOXIC
COMBINATION FOR THE REST OF US.
THAT IS WHY IT HAS LED TO
INFLATION NATION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LATEST POLLS,
SEAN, THREE QUICK THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, 54% DISAPPROVE OF
JOE BIDEN'S HANDLING OF THE
ECONOMY.
HE HAS GIVEN US INFLATION
NATION.
NUMBER TWO, INFLATION IS NOW
TIED WITH KOVIC AS THE MAJOR
CONCERN IN AMERICA.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MOMENT.
THAT IS BECAUSE THE COST OF
LIVING IS SOMETHING PEOPLE NEED
TO GRAPPLE WITH.
THE SAME FOLKS WHO BENEFITED,
THE BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS, ON
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE TAX CUT
AND JOBS ACT UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
DEREGULATION OF SMALL BUSINESS
BOOM UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY
ARE NOW SUFFERING UNDER
JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES AND
INFLATION IS TIED WITH COVID.
NUMBER THREE, IT IS THE
PESSIMISM WE SEE GOING FORWARD.
46% OF THE PEOPLE IN CNBC POLL
SAY THE ECONOMY WILL BE WORSE IN
THE NEXT YEAR, THE HIGHEST
NUMBER SINCE 2008, WHEN WE HAD
AN ECONOMIC COLLAPSE.
YOU DON'T SEE ANY END INSIGHT.
>> Sea